is making movies still where your
passion's at you're playing Tyson aren't
you yeah we're gonna play Tyson I met
Mike Tyson when I was 21. you know we
all doing a stand-up comedy at that time
I'm in the hood I'm doing a joke and I'm
killing LA and I get to my Mike Tyson
joke and that's where I usually I get a
Standing Ovation full crowd all black
get to my Mike Tyson joke and nobody
laugh somebody here Mike is in here
and it's back at the time when Mike is
knocking people out for heaven on the
wrong shirt you know I came out to you
if you go ahead you do it but it better
be funny so I do the joke and it was a
[__] joke it was something like I
drove to Kentucky Fried Chicken and I
heard through the drive-through hi
welcome to the Fried Chicken yeah can I
get chicken chicken and biscuit from
store
Standing Ovation [__] is going crazy
Mike Tyson realtor you're so funny
you're crazy coming out you want to hang
out with you and I get in the car with
Mike and I just start hanging out with
this [__] I was like the gesture
like whenever you need somebody laughing
you make me laugh [__] knock knock knock